[Music]
the new the batman with robert patterson
is getting mostly positive reviews these
days and is already a complete success
in addition to the rumors about a
planned trilogy with patterson there is
now also official information about
other projects from the same universe it
have been known for a while that the
batman would be the start of a new
universe of its own consisting not only
of movies but also series one of them
was the series titled gotham central
which was supposed to take place in
bruce wayne's first year as batman and
thus a bit before the events of the
batman the focus would have been a
police officer of the gotham city police
department but as matt reeves recently
announced in the conversation with the
cybernerds the direction of the series
is probably changing fundamentally the
project he has planned will now focus on
the infamous arkham asylum the series is
supposed to resemble a horror movie and
offer a fresh perspective on the
characters incarcerated there which
traditionally consists of villains like
the ritter joker two-face poison ivy and
co in addition the asylum is one of the
favorite places of batman fans whether
in one of the numerous video games or in
various movies and series nothing is
known yet about the exact plot but it
could of course be that we'll be dealing
with an escape attempt from the asylum a
second dc eu series is also in the works
this project will also feature villain
none other than penguin after the events
of the batman the mobster who's superbly
portrayed by colin pharrell sees his
chance as come to grab for supremacy in
gotham city in addition to some
flashbacks the main focus will be on how
the unscrupulous gangster develops into
the boss of bosses again the batman
director matt reeves has his eye on the
production but agents of shield writer
lauren lefranc is responsible as
showrunner we are definitely looking
forward to both series and new news from
the batman universe unfortunately there
is no stardate for the project yet it is
only known that the penguin series will
be filmed in the near future
today danny vilnav's science fiction
epic june has grossed almost 400 million
us dollars and was also very well
received by critics fortunately it has
been clear for some time that the
blockbuster will get at least one if not
two sequels production on tune 2 has
been underway for several weeks now and
slowly but surely the first news about
potential new editions is emerging as
deadline reports a marvel star is
currently in talks for role and that is
black widow star florence pugh the 26
year old is currently in negotiations
with warner brothers allegedly for the
role of princess ireland carino the
character should be familiar to
connoisseurs of frank herbert's books
since she is the daughter of emperor
shattam corrino iv in the book princess
ireland is more of a minor character
acting primarily as the author of the
recurring history book that appears at
the beginning of each chapter she does
take on a larger role in the later
course however if dany vulnera's
narrative pace matches that of part one
she will only become important in a
potential third part this doesn't seem
completely hopeless after all director
velnev definitely has plans to produce a
third and this final movie in any case
we are looking forward to more news
about dune 2 and the release date of
october 20th 2023
a few days ago the us magazine deadline
announced that a late sequel to the end
time movie i am legend was in the works
almost 15 years after the first part
this announcement was extremely
surprising but there is even more
information about the cast already
according to this lead actor will smith
will return as dr robert neville which
certainly inspires speculation
considering his fate at the end of i'm
legend the most likely theory is that
the alternate ending of i'm legend will
be seen as canon and built upon similar
to the book in the movie ending neville
sacrifices himself to allow anna and
ethan to escape in the alternate ending
neville realized that the test subject
he kidnapped is the partner of the
infected leader and that is the reason
they are attacking his house he realized
that the creatures are intelligent
communicate with each other and live in
their own social groupings this makes
him the real villain even with his
experiments as a result he breaks off
his research and travels to vermont with
anna and ethan where he realized that
he's not as righteous as he thought in
addition to will smith there is also
fresh support from black panther star
michael b jordan who will slip into a
yet unknown role they do also make a
good team behind the camera as they will
also serve as producers of i'm legend 2.
the script comes from i'm legend and
sacrilege author akiva goldsman we're
definitely looking forward to the late
i'm legend sequel and will of course
keep you up to date on further news
about the plot or the start date
march 9th evening
suddenly a shock to the force the
long-awaited teaser trailer for the
obi-wan kenobi series appears and
millions of fan hearts cry out with joy
the overwhelming reactions are extremely
positive manny had been looking forward
to reunion with ewan mcgregor in his
parade role as he is one of the most
popular characters of the star wars
series the series is set a good 10 years
after star wars episode 3 revenge of the
sith in the trailer we see obi-wan
hiding on tatooine watching over a young
luke skywalker from afar but disaster is
on the way the empire does not sleep and
sends out the dreaded inquisitors to
hunt down the last remaining jedi
obviously the series is not limited to
the desert planet we see sinister fouls
on their opponents in all sorts of
places talking lightsabers and blasters
one voice talks about how the jedi can't
help but feel compassion so what would
be more obvious than committing
atrocities against civilians to draw
them out fans can look forward to
reunion with joel edgard as luke's uncle
or lars among others who witnesses the
atrocities and the trailer obi-wan will
have to decide intervene and fight the
empire or stand down to avoid putting
luke in danger by the way nothing could
be seen of hayden christensen as darth
vader in the trailer but the distinctive
breathing can be clearly heard at the
end and makes you want more the star
date for this tower series obi-wan
kenobi is may 25th 2022 on disney plus
we have a pretty darn good feeling about
this one
actually it looked quite good for movie
fans this year but as was already
announced dc fans in particular will now
have to bite the bullet despite the
success of the batman it was decided to
postpone some movies no longer released
this year will be the flash and aquaman
and the lost kingdom instead tc will
only release three movies this year
including dc league of super pets on
july 29 2022 black adam on october 21st
2022 and shazam 2 fury of the gods on
december 16 2022. at least that's good
news for fans of shazam 2 as that has
been moved up from 2023 to this year
next year aquaman in the lost kingdom
will probably be released on march 17th
the flash on june 23rd as well as the
two wander brothers movies mack to the
trench on august 4th and wonka on
december 15th but you shouldn't be too
sad because we can still expect all
kinds of blockbusters from marvel as
well as the last jurassic world part on
june 10th 2022
alien from 1979 was nothing less than a
milestone in the science fiction genre
and still regularly inspires movie
lovers all over the world unfortunately
after the first two parts the
aspirations of movie critics and fans
could not really be met and the sequels
drew mediocre reviews at most the two
prequels prometheus and alien covenant
excluded even the planned fifth part
with director neil bloomkamp and the
return of michael bean and sigone weaver
probably did not meet the requirements
for a successful alien movie the project
was rumored to have been scrapped by
order of ridley scott as the hollywood
reporter now reports the 84 year old
scott wants to produce a completely new
movie in collaboration with evil dead
director fed alvarez the director who's
at home in the horror genre certainly
has a knack for suspenseful movies as he
impressively proved with the thriller
don't brief the project is supposed to
stand completely on its own and have no
connection to the predecessors which
could please the fans of the franchise
the type of release is seen much more
critically because alvarez's new movie
is not to be released in theaters but on
the streaming service hulu in countries
where hulu does not exist we expect a
release on disney plus similar to many
other hulu exclusives unfortunately the
release date of the new alien movie is
not yet known
everyone knows the little italian wooden
figure whose nose keeps growing when he
lies sure we're talking about pinocchio
this character has been part of disney's
movie universe since 1940 and will be
getting a new live-action movie version
on disney plus this year fittingly there
was already a first picture of the two
main characters pinocchio and mr gipatto
while the wooden boy gets his voice led
by 13 year old benjamin evan ainsworth
and is of course cg animated hollywood
superstar tom hanks plays the kindly old
woodcarver at first glance the closeness
to the original striking after all in
the past disney oft made the decision to
give old familiar characters a
completely new coat of paint in favor of
diversity and variety pinocchio and
geppetto on the other hand look as if
they came straight out of the animated
movie adaption which has made many fans
optimistic the script is by rogue one
and star wars story writer chris white
while robert zemeckis is responsible for
directing an exact release date for
disney plus is not yet known but those
responsible have announced that it will
be in september
in 2005 sony undisputedly launched one
of the most celebrated game series of
all time with god of war after the last
installment of 2018 which is considered
by many to be the best game of all time
celebrated countless successes it was
only a matter of time before we would
see kratos in a movie or a serious
adaption according to a report from
deadline amazon is currently in
negotiations with sony about a series
with the greek demigod if the deal does
go through the expense produces mark
fergus and hawk ospy as well as the
wheel of time showron and rave judkins
are said to be in charge of course it
will be too early to speculate on plot
of characters appearing as the series
adaption has yet to be officially
announced either way amazon is moving
further and further in the direction of
video game adaptions we already reported
for example on a mass effect and a
fallout series both of which are already
in production
that's it for this week's news we can
also recommend our latest original about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and of course you can find the
brand new trailer for the obi-wan kenobi
series on our channel so be sure to
check it out may the force be with you
till next week
[Music]
you